Now, any city can be a harbor city...
...say researchers at the Korea Advanced Institute of Science and Technology.
Institute President Suh Nam-pyo says he got the idea for the mobile harbor on a trip to Singapore.
I saw all these ships waiting out there.
My guess was that they were there waiting for their turns to load and unload their cargo.
So I said, "Why should ships come into the harbor, right?"
"Why not have the harbor go out there and then just bring the goods in?"
Researchers describe the mobile harbor as a lean, light system...
...for unloading container ships even if the coastal area is too shallow for them to dock.
Specially designed cargo barges would head out...
...to meet and unload gigantic container ships along any coastline.
The vessels will have the advantage of being able to navigate shallow water and squeeze through rivers.
At the shore, they then will offload onto specially designed receiving platforms.
It sounds easy but Senior Engineer Gwak Byung-man admits there are daunting technical challenges.
The ocean is always rippling...
...and especially for smaller boats.
It is extremely hard to load and unload containers in a stable way.
So our main challenges are, how do we stabilize the vessel itself in all those waves?
And second, how do we stabilize the loading equipment aboard the vessel?
An institute exhibition displays the project's obsession with stability.
Pulleys, axles and shock absorbers document researchers' efforts to deal with the rolling waves.